la mode est aux énergies renouvelables
et depuis peu les éoliennes font tourner
les têtes
la france compte aujourd'hui plus de
2000 de ses turbines géantes qui
produisent de l'électricité grâce au
vent mais avec le grenelle de
l'environnement le gouvernement voudrait
en installer quatre fois plus d'ici à
2020 sur terre et en mer
mais dans certaines régions comme en
auvergne l'éolien fait souffler le vent
de la discorde et la guerre fait rage
entre pro et anti
séoul et nianan ses joueuses ou est a
lyon je suppose à ce que ça fait on sait
maintenant que ça prend que des
nuisances c'est chez des gens ça
provoque des ligues et des gens qui sont
malades à cause de ça d'autres ont
trouvé le moyen de ne plus recevoir de
factures d'électricité en installant une
éolienne dans leur jardin et un français
a même mis au point une éolienne qui
pourrait bien résoudre le problème de
pénurie d'eau sur la planète
cette semaine combien ça coûte l'hebdo
est plus que jamais dans le vent
bienvenue à salles curan dans l'aveyron
son château datant du moyen-âge sa
superbe église du xvème siècle mais ce
ne sont pas ses bâtiments historiques
qui font la fierté de monsieur le maire
en ce moment c'est plutôt le centre
médicalisée flambant neuf qui l'a
inauguré l'année dernière ça a coûté un
million et demi d'euros la mairie en a
financé la moitié
mais pour ces mille administrés rien
n'est trop beau
l'étagère il y avait pris chez le kiné
de la piste comment un petit village d'à
peine 1000 habitants at il bien pu se
payer une installation pareil en fait
des sociétés ont investi dans la région
il propose d'installer des éoliennes
chez des particuliers contre de l'argent
résultat 29 éoliennes de 125 m ont
poussé dans la campagne et elle rapporte
chaque année plus de 50000 euros à la
mairie de taxes en tous genres mais ici
dans la région du lévézou ces éoliennes
ne font pas que des heureux à commencer
par tous ceux qui vivent ou travaillent
à proximité des installations
ce matin réunion de crise pour des
habitants au bord de la crise de nerfs
au départ personne n'était contre les
éoliennes
moi la première gt des voix manquantes
et les augmenter oui oui tout compte
fait sauf qu après qu en 10 inventer une
et deux et trois bandes
et puis après quand on arrive à 29 on
dit mais c'est pas possible ce n'est pas
parce que si je sors sur mon mail co
j'ai l'impression d'être au bord de
l'aéroport moi j'ai passé six mois sans
trop y prêter gauche et alain derrière
la lah sur le côté on a devant l'ars en
levant le maintenant tourner la plus de
paysage en un paysage magnifique sauvage
accueillant pourtant et on a on a en
face les éoliennes
ils ne peuvent même plus les voir en
peinture et jean marc qui est bien
décidé à nous montrer pourquoi jean
c'est un peu le don quichotte local
doublé d'un redoutable scientifique des
nuisances et une d'une éolienne de 125
mètres de haut comme celle-là ce sens et
95 décibels c'est prouvé par une étude
de la dde c'est exactement le bruit de
cet a319
ça n'en a peut-être pas l'air comme ça
mais une éolienne quand ça souffle ça
peut s'entendre des kilomètres à la
ronde
pas de chance pour monique ses voisins
en ont fait installer partout autour de
chez elle a à peine 500 mètres de sa
maison
sa vie est devenue un enfer nous en
avons de 13,6 de klein et ces sept là je
sais pas qui c'est qui voudrait avoir
une éolienne à cinq mètres de sa maison
et elle tourne 24 heures sur 24 monique
et son mari ont dû carrément changer de
chambre à coucher
ça commençait alors taper sur le système
c'est ça faisait trop de bruit et mon
mari n'arrivait pas à dormir
j'y passais les knees sur lequel le
fauteuil jusqu'à il ya peu monique ne
pouvait même pas regarder la télévision
tranquille voyez la télé maintenant le
marche mais avait un gars avec les au
début et bien ne marchait pas et avec
les ondes des éoliennes et c'est là tout
était ok on n'y voyait plus et
d'ailleurs on en a peu on appelait le
promoteur nous taper il nous a payé une
parabole et tout le village a été équipé
départ à bonn pour la cause de ses
origines
ça fait partie de leur stratégie
commerciale pour acheter le silence est
quelque part de ceux qui se plaignent de
payer les paraboles à tout le monde
comme proposé des double vitrage aussi à
à ceux qui se plaignent du bruit
les éoliennes serait une source de
nuisance alors comment se fait-il que
des propriétaires acceptent encore que
des promoteurs les installe sur leur
terrain
pour le savoir nous décidons de rendre
visite à l'un de ces agriculteurs qui a
justement accepté d'en faire construire
chez lui
mais l'homme est très discret sur ses
réelles motivations
avon importe combien
lien sur votre terrain et ça vous
rapporteront
alors apporté temps d'antenne à tourner
alors
devant notre insistance la conversation
va vite tourné court
circulez ya rien à voir
en réalité une éolienne sur son terrain
ça se monnaye très cher au moins 6000
euros par an et pendant 15 ans si ça
continue comme ça il y aura bientôt plus
d'éoliennes que deux volcans en auvergne
pourtant malgré la polémique
rien ne semble pouvoir entraver la
marche forcée des éoliennes aujourd'hui
la panne depuis deux semaines c'est
comme ça l'éolienne et soeurs fournit
près de montpellier pierre n'a vraiment
pas à se plaindre de sa petite éolienne
elle fait moins de douze mètres de haut
donc pas besoin de déposer un permis de
construire et elle produit toute
l'électricité dont il a besoin
pierre à même de quoi tenir un siège et
quand une vague de froid s'abat sur la
france ces radiateurs marche à plein
régime sans avoir à se soucier de sa
facture d'électricité
on peut voir ici que j'aimais batterie
qui sera 280 290 walt le parc est plein
et depuis une semaine je suis toute la
consommation électrique liens de
l'éolienne et je suis en autosuffisance
même s'ils vont s'arrêter de souffler il
aurait de quoi s'alimenter pendant
quatre jours sa petite installation ne
lui a coûté que 6000 euros grâce au
crédit d'impôt et aux aides de la région
trois fois moins que le prix sur
catalogue et depuis un an il n'a plus
reçu une seule facture d'électricité
j'estime économiser 200 euros par mois
sur mes dépenses énergétiques et donc en
tenant compte du crédit d'impôt est
demeuré dz
je pense amortir mon achat sur quatre
ans pour moi
edf c'est ma mère aux vieilles pierres
n'est pas le seul la france est l'un des
pays européens où il ya le plus de vent
du coup ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à planter une éolienne dans
leur jardin
beaucoup de petits constructeurs sont
arrivés sur le marché et les innovations
se multiplient comme par exemple cette
éolienne en forme de boule ou encore
celle ci axe vertical même le célèbre
designer philippe starck en a dessiné
une toute petite à peine quelques
dizaines de centimètres et transparente
s'il vous plaît de quoi transformer
votre balcon en petite usine avant
l'innovation de marc parent elles ne
représentent pour l'instant qu'une toute
petite goutte d'eau dans l'océan du
marché éolien mais une goutte d'eau
potable
vernis très bonne produire de
l'électricité et de l'eau avec du vent
c'est ce que fait cette éolienne unique
au monde
marc a travaillé d'arrache-pied pendant
dix ans dans le petit garage de ses
parents pour mettre au point cette
invention qui pourrait faire de lui un
homme très riche
partout autour de nous il ya de
l'humidité dans l'air comme cette la
chine
c'est simplement machine à faire de la
pluie elle va aspirer l'air ici par ce
grand theater et le pousser dans la
chambre en augmentation ici nous allons
séparer la laque bordeaux nous a
transformé la condenser en mots à l'état
liquide fois primée par cet orifice
voilà ta de chou ou le lot de l'air
cette machine permet de recueillir
jusqu'à 100 litres d'eau par jour soit
la moitié de ce que consomment un
individu mais son créateur travaille
aujourd'hui sur un prototype dix fois
plus efficace des pays d'afrique et du
moyen-orient l'ont déjà approché avec
son éolienne marque pourrait bien
devenir millionnaire